welcome back to dc thursdays
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council and the data community fund
and i'm happy to have another amazing
guest
on the show as you know we interview the
leaders of the modern data ecosystem
either creators of open source tools
interesting data projects
or founders of data companies and i'm
really excited to have
tristan science here today he's from
continual iq
um kristin has tristan has some uh
really interesting thoughts
on ai and the monitoring data stack and
he and i have been having conversations
about sort of
what's missing in the modern cloud data
stack and
today we'll be talking about ml ops and
perhaps a way that you haven't
thought of before um and we'll also hear
some of tristan's thoughts on
declarative ai so tristan is currently
the founder of a company called
continual iq
formerly he was the cto for machine
learning at cloudera
and previously he was the co-founder of
a company called
sense which was an early company in the
data science tooling space
before that he was a visiting fellow at
the institute
for quantitative social science at
harvard so
tristan with that i want to welcome you
to the show
thanks pete i appreciate that and i'll
corral make one small correction which
is the name of the startup is now
continual we actually we actually when
we were just incorporating we called it
continual iq
because we couldn't get a domain name
for continual uh but we managed to
shorten it down so continual uh
continual ai if anybody wants to check
it out
that's right thanks for thanks for
having me thanks for having me
the the site is continual dot ai now is
that correct
that's right that's right awesome okay
well yeah um
it's really a pleasure to have you and
we've known each other for a couple
years now
and um it's been great to see sort of
your your quiet work behind the scenes
at continual but i'm hoping that maybe
you'll be able to share a little bit
more
about some of that with us today yeah no
absolutely
it's excited to be here thanks for
having me so um
i just want to start at the beginning
and
comment that your phd is in public
policy so how does this translate into
uh running or starting a data science
tooling company
yeah i know i get that question a lot
i've actually on linkedin i think i just
removed my uh you know a link to my
dissertation or something because i was
like okay i have enough uh
enough experience here now in the
enterprise data science and machine
learning space that i don't need to
don't need to talk about my sort of my
earlier life but yeah no it's uh
it's actually i mean it's a common like
i guess i can
uh you know go back you know way back um
you know i'm old enough now
uh sort of embarrassingly to have
participated in really
the dot com one uh experience
so i graduated high school in 1998 which
was really when that whole internet was
taking off
i had taken cs classes in you know even
in high school
i was i knew how to build software in
college i actually did a few startups
like small startups including some that
actually were successful maybe even more
successful
uh than uh my previous startup that
would that got acquired
uh you know it was one of the fastest
growing sites on did one was one of the
fastest growing sites on the internet
you know thousands of users signing up
per day which was actually an amazing
thing
back then um and so so always have been
somebody who's been sort of tracking
technology
know how to build software you know like
building stuff kind of have an
entrepreneurial
event um then ended up you know as you
guys are pointing out kind of ended up
spending my
uh my 20s in in academia and and
sort of uh you know applying i mean in
academia i ended up doing a lot of work
on data
um data science i guess what you called
now data science my dissertation was all
on bayesian statistics and causal
inference
it was in the public public policy
domain but i was always the person sort
of building the software doing the data
analysis
uh yeah you know and even my research
ended up being really around
econometrics which is the sort of
statistics within the economic
discipline that's what they call it
um yeah so it's a little bit you know
and then i think that early
uh taste of entrepreneurship
and success and building something and
putting it out and having it go viral
and
be successful was always there in the
back of my mind and throws throughout
grad school i was always
thinking of you know business ideas
thinking of things to build
you know uh and uh ultimately it was you
know
coming out of grad school the decision
was you know do become a professor
uh or do a startup and you know ended up
uh you know couldn't resist the
adventure
really of of of doing startups and
building things and
you know trying to try to make things
that are in your mind a reality which
there's an element of that i think in
academia i mean part of the appeal of
academia as well is
the ability to kind of think creativity
you know creatively about about the
future and
you know things that might not be
obvious to everybody um and
uh that's part of academia which is you
know definitely
you know i still find that appealing but
there's a there's another version of
that in
in the startup world which is very
similar actually intellectually
but has this power of uh you know you
actually can make it real and take it to
the next step
and and kind of deliver it into the
world versus just you know writing up a
paper and
publishing and kind of you know crossing
your fingers that some other
other person operationalizes it yeah
the direct access to that impact is
definitely exciting
um so you and you ended up starting this
company
basically in the early days of data
science tooling
um essentially this is the first startup
yeah yeah called set
called sense that you that you sold to
ultimately sold to cloudera
um tell us the story about sense and how
that company came to be
yeah so um was coming out of grad school
this was around 2012
2013 when that when that company was was
sort of being born and really was seeing
the rise of data science as a term so
the rise
of data science is a term the rise of
this emerging class of user called a
data scientist
the rise of open source data science
tools so things like python and r
becoming increasingly the dominant tool
that you know anybody doing data
analysis wanted to use
that's contrasted with you know the
historical tools that even i was
using in grad school things like stata
and spss and sas and matlab
right these are sort of proprietary
statistical computing
tools but that was clearly not where the
future was was going
there was also at that time the rise of
big data right so the rise of the hadoop
ecosystem
the rise of spark uh um and
then a kind of a background parallel
trend was just
the movement to the cloud right there
just the reality that we're going to
move away from our laptops towards the
cloud we're going to do things at scale
um and so that sort of created you know
i could just smell that wow
there needs to be a new approach to
doing data data
statistical analysis data science there
needs to be a platform for data
scientists and so what sense was
was really uh one of the first really
one of the first enterprise data science
platforms it was
you know there's three small startups at
the time um that were
probably we were all right in the at the
same moment trying to
realize this this uh vision um
and uh you know it ended up kind of
gelling together um
in terms of what that meant you know
giving a collaboration environment for
data scientists
you know starting to help them uh be
able to operationalize or productionize
things schedule their jobs you know but
this is all sort of code first
um kind of you know classic and now
there's a whole another generation right
now the the public clouds have adopted
you know we have sagemaker we have
vertex ai
we have azure ml uh we have databricks
of course which is you know it's done
tremendous
job particularly powered by that
underlying data platform of
uh you know that they get from spark and
you know the whole ecosystem that
they've developed there
um so yeah that was uh you know
yeah i mean i can go much much deeper in
i mean we
uh you know we we we were small we were
you know we basically were seed funded
we got the initial product market fit
it became a category it also became
clear that hey where this is an
enterprise
uh uh one this is sort of an enterprise
software game right ultimately the the
people that are gonna pay for this are
within the enterprise
um and so that entails a whole bunch of
you know how it's deployed it's still
at that point you know cloud was still a
challenge um
especially within large enterprise so we
were getting a lot of pull to go on prem
um and of course there was also a sort
of a
a we could see a trend that it would be
very powerful to attach this
uh experience to the underlying
underlying data platform an underlying
platform so databricks has that with
their
kind of core platform the public clouds
have that obviously with their
uh hyperscale platforms and cloudera had
a data platform
really we was the leading provider of
hadoop you know was the dominant
uh at scale data platform particularly
on-prem
um recognized that machine learning and
ai were the most exciting were kind of
the ultimate
workload for data right that's sort of
the top of the value pyramid
um and data scientists were the type of
user that they really needed to bring to
the platform
hadoop was traditionally quite more more
engineering kind of java oriented
uh and so you know it was clear that
they you know
wanted to get it you know wanted to get
into this area and um
you know we were just kind of at the
right time right level of maturity for
them and we so they ended up making an
offer and joined them
and that product since became their data
science workbench product
data science workbench yep got it yeah
now it's i think they have a they have a
cloud version of it called cloudera
uh machine learning but was very
successful for them i mean the general
strategy of
you know making that that data platform
easier bringing more workloads onto it
enabling data scientists um you know uh
it was a kind of a compelling value
proposition for sure so then
is your sense that cloudera wanted to
compete with
data robot who's also in the same
category
um or or that it was a valid more of a
value add
the data science workbench was more of a
value add for the overall clutter
platform
so i wouldn't put a you know data robot
i would you know which is the kind of
automl focus company um that was also
actually started
actually kind of parallel but wasn't
really the code first platform that was
targeting data scientists
right that was giving you python as the
kind of core
ingredient of your workflow um so i
don't think there was a there was never
a desire
a clutter to compete with a data robot i
think there was a recognition
um that you did need to bring data
scientists onto your platform because
data science workloads were critical
that data scientists wanted to use
languages like you know python as their
kind of core language
they wanted to use you know in the big
data ecosystem they also wanted to use
spark
so uh you know and then uh so they
mainly wanted to stay you know bring
those new users on bring those workloads
on
and they could also see obviously the
rise of data bricks uh
you know which you know has a you know
took spark and then put a notebook the
first thing they did was put a notebook
you know based uh experience on top of
that right um to make it easier
for people to to use what would
otherwise be complicated technology
so yeah it was really about that merging
class of use cases
got it um and so like
how how is the rest just so we can sort
of understand the rest of the context at
this
at this point in time um how how do you
see the rest of the competition
in the market shaping up sort of around
sense slash
data science workbench at the time like
who were those competitors
um you mentioned a couple of startups
that that you competed with when you
first started the company
i'm just curious how that um world
emerged because sometimes we get lessons
from
um you know how things might sort of run
in parallel
later on yeah i know and i'm not sure
that all the new startups doing ml ops
and
notebooks and are aware of the fact that
the story i think this trend really
started with
in the 2012 2013 era um so prior to 2012
2013 um you know there was basically lap
but you know there was jupiter notebook
on your own laptop
right uh so that was that that was the
open source python here's a notebook for
yourself
that's an open source but the dominant i
mean the dominant tool within the
enterprise was sas
sas right which is this you know nobody
even talks about anymore but has three
billion dollars in revenue
i think it's i just heard that they
might be getting they're privately held
they're you know kind of an
idiosyncratic company but they have
their birth
in the 70s 70s actually then became the
dominant statistical platform in the 80s
but they had all the things that
enterprises needed right they had the
support
the scheduling the connectivity to the
underlying data platform
and so they had you know sas was the one
company that
really managed to do advanced you know
with advanced analytics right statistics
what they would call that
uh in an enterprise way right and they
had a core platform and then they
started to have modules
you know supply chain optimization or
hotel management operates optimization
or
marketing and sales um so they were the
company that had managed to move to the
enterprise managed to generate
you know billions of dollars in revenue
um and and that was there were there
were also
a handful of these you know spss and you
know from that ibm bot
and stata which is in big in the
economics world you know r was big in
the statistical community but
you know for the research community in
fact r was more dominant from a research
perspective than python because python
really didn't have the
data frame ecosystem so that's where
that that was the 2000 era
you know 2012 era there was in parallel
to that then the rise
two parallel rises one the rise of
python uh as
as the kind of really the the the
language for machine learning uh and the
rise of the big data ecosystem you know
spark being a big part of that hadoop
being a big part of that
um and i think that sort of changed the
game so
so or provided an opportunity that
clearly these previous companies weren't
going to be the ones that were going to
win
and so then a new class of startups came
out we were one of them
uh domino datalabs was another one which
was very similar to what we were doing
there was another company called y hat
at the time that got acquired by alteryx
uh that was very similar and databricks
to databricks credit was you know also
in that era but they had
uh you know i think the secret sauce of
of spark
um which really gave them the scale
around computing
data and so there you know in some ways
in terms of the true breakout company
the independent breakup company from
that era you know they i think they came
in maybe six months after we did
and we were all looking at one another
and you know from the user experience
and workflow perspective
they had the foundation of spark which
was you know in some ways quite
different
got it um so
so you ended up uh leaving cloudera and
um essentially you decided that you
wanted to start a new company and i
think this takes us more forward in sort
of the modern
um world and and how you saw the data
stack
emerging so i'm curious like what were
you seeing
um at the time before you started a
continual and
what was it that inspired you and
motivated you what was the key insight
that led you to start continual yeah
so that's a that's a good question um so
yeah i was at cloudera for three years
had a great time there you know
you know love my time there met tons of
great people you know the
product was successful so it was ended
up being a very uh happy journey for
myself and i think for the product as
well
um in the you know sort of in the last
year i would say
particularly at cloudera which was you
know sort of the two uh
you know two years ago um the number one
you know i was i was in the role of sort
of cto for ml which kind of had a little
bit of an outbound role a little bit of
technical leadership internal to the
team we had formed a business unit and
whatnot
um and you know in talking with all
these companies
the number one thing i heard again and
again and again
was how do i get all my models into
production how do i operationalize them
and that was the big struggle right they
had built data science teams
they had bought a data platform they'd
gotten their data together
they had done some r d sort of projects
but they were all
struggling to operationalize and
productionize
more than one model right they might get
one model into production if it was a
little static model they might
throw it over the fence and it's now
it's on an api and they got a flask
endpoint they maybe load balanced it
with kubernetes or something like that
but they didn't really they all had
visions of
we are going to be an ai first
enterprise right they had bought in all
the company i didn't need to go and show
them my slide on
you know why the future is going to be
ai first and every leading company is
going to
embed you know ai across their business
right i had those slides
but often they would show me those
slides right they would show me they
were you know if you talk to banks if
you talk to pharma if you talk to
telecom
um if you especially at the big
companies right where billions of
dollars are throwing
flowing through those businesses there
is just
everywhere you know there's
opportunities to to do predictions
and to have millions of dollars in
return right at smaller scale companies
it's going to be a little bit a harder
because
the returns often are maybe the same
percentage basis but the absolute basis
doesn't justify if the complexity is
high doesn't justify it
but there was a you know there was total
belief that there were hundreds and
hundreds of applications for them to do
um but they weren't you know really
seeing necessarily all the roi
and their own diagnosis of that problem
was hey we're really struggling to get
to production
so that was the number one thing hey we
and that's not a unique insight right in
some ways like you know the whole rise
of ml ops as a
as a kind of category theme you know is
is
people widely understand that this you
know it's kind of almost a cliche like
you know
x percent of models don't get the
production you know you get kind of
mocked if you kind of
say that but it's true i mean it's true
in the sense that
you know people are not embedding ai
across their business at the velocity
that they would like
right and i and particularly the
companies that i talked to at cloudera
which are not silicon valley tech
companies
they're mainstream you know fortune 2000
right
global businesses that are you know that
that are sophisticated but also
uh you know you know practical right
their core business is not necessarily
technology um there was a lot of uh
challenge there
and then i would look at the solutions
that you know we were offering at
cloudera but also just
the marketplace was offering even the
public clouds to that problem
that i was hearing again and again and
what we would show is a stack diagram
that would had seven different
distributed systems inside of it right
so if you look at
you know the uber michael you know
michelangelo platform from uber which
has been blogged about it's kind of like
nice little reference
uh platform you know if you look at that
thing and you actually look at every box
there there's seven or eight different
distributed systems
there's three plus yeah you realize this
is bigger than just
uh model serving like it's this is not
just a model serving
problem it's bigger than that yeah this
is not a mod this is not putting a model
in a container right now you know on one
hand you have these toy solutions
i would call them kind of toy data
science platforms which are saying oh i
can wrap a model in an api uh you know
and put it as a flask app and put it
under kubernetes and oh i haven't you
know i have solved some big problems
oh i mean we already know how to do that
i mean sres know how to do that there's
little things around
monitoring you know data drift and
whatnot that's not the hard problem
the hard problem is the continual nature
of most enterprise machine learning
applications where
data is continually coming in the world
is continually changing i need to store
my historical data for training purposes
i need current data for you know current
inference purposes whether that's real
time or whether that's batch
my model has to be updated not every
hour but i mean it has to be updated
every
on some basis so the model is now living
the model is being trained regularly
you know the inference is being done uh
the whole thing needs to be monitored
and so what you end up having is you
know you have
you know i mean if you're if you're in
cloudera you have you know you know
historical hdfs and
you know h whatever hbase for historical
stuff you have spark and stream
processing for
data engineering you have you know we
have all the bits but the complexity is
is uh is is high is high and the clouds
you know some people think oh that's a
you know that
that's the problem with hadoop or
something no i mean that's just the
problem with every stack diagram that
i've seen out there if you go and you
look at
what sagemaker shows you or you look at
what uh you know vertex ai from google
show you
um you know if you actually care about
the continual
ml operations aspect right not just like
hey i want to train a notebook or i want
to train a job
but i want this thing to be humming
along right people's public perception
of ai is that
this thing is learning right it's
getting better and better and better and
if you want to if you want that you want
that for your company and you want to
have
not just one or two models but you want
to have dozens of models
then you end up with this incredibly
complicated system
and uh you know that's uh frustrating
it doesn't seem necessary to me so i
mean i you know you know i think there's
i think there's a solution to that
uh you know or um that doesn't just
involve you know
you know pipeline jungles and everything
i think we need to come up with a much
higher level of abstraction to think
about operational ai which is what
continual is about
as really finding a higher level of
abstraction to
you know 10x simplify the time to build
models you know 10x you know reduce the
cost to maintain them
you know 10x you know increase the
velocity and ease of
improving the model so it tends to be
these three phases right you need to for
operate for production models you need
to you build them right
and once you build one you build a churn
model you typically build a churn model
for 30 days for 60 days for 90 days
for you know net expansion net
contraction product upsell so
quickly if it becomes easy to build
these models
you know you want a lot of them and then
so you so you want that process to be
fast
where you can reuse your work and then
second hey if your model's in production
don't you definitely don't want to be
tied down with a maintenance crisis
or maintainability cost so you want it
to be really easy to maintain which is
very hard in these pipeline jungle you
know kind of situations you know you
off-board team members you onboard team
members
and then you want to then you iterate
right you have new features you import a
new data source you have new signals the
model decays in some way so you need to
change
you know change the inputs to it
probably not the model architecture
honestly
um like that probably don't need to
change or maybe change it kind of
independently
um so you won't also want to have it be
faster right so continual is really
about that and i
i mean i can go into more of that so
so so i got the i got this notion that
you wanted to um create a higher level
abstraction that
um covered a lot of similar things in
your
example of this this michelangelo
reference architecture
um so you felt like some of those things
had to be sort of
abstracted away and made simpler to use
for for modern
modern enterprises you also mentioned an
interesting term that i want to dig into
a little bit more which is
operational ai so
how do you think of operational ai as
being different
than other kinds of ai can you just sort
of walk us through like what your
mental model is for thinking about like
what is operational ai and how do you
define that
yeah yeah um so
no i think there's one domain of ai
which is i would call it research
right which is you know where you where
you're you know you're essentially
trying to you know just experiment with
models and you know build models but
essentially you have a research style
workflow right in that world
what you want is you want notebooks you
want you know collaboration features
you want experiment tracking right so
the weights and biases of the world
right you want to be able to as a
researcher maybe you want you know
a training platform or grid or you know
determined or something like that that
gives you worse you know whatever the
stage maker equivalents
but you're basically going to train
models you're going to explore things in
a notebook
and you need a product you need to track
your experiments so that you have some
you can keep track of what's working
what's not but it's kind of a r d it's
very similar to what goes on in
a research lab right and i would say a
lot of the early platforms out there for
data science
were solving that they started with
notebooks right then they added
experiment tracking
right you know you could collaborate you
could you know you're going to do work
with the team so
you could you know you're going to get
access to compute resources so how can i
get access to a gpu
you know that's going to be that's the
cloud right maybe they should live in
the cloud
but there were there are platforms
really that were geared towards our r d
um i would say there's one level like up
from that which is you know you're doing
r d and then you take a little
serialized model
and you stick it somewhere you stick it
in the container you stick it on a
on a phone right it can recognize an
image you know it can do something but
you don't have a
it's not a process where you know the
data is continually changing the
changing training data is continually
changing there's features that are kind
of coming in from some complicated
backend systems
uh it doesn't have that right it's
basically you pass an image in you get a
classification out right
that's a world that kind of can live in
that the workflow can be r d oriented
pass over that model you know maybe you
train it retrain it every six months or
something too it's relatively static
it's relatively sad so for me the
operational ai
you know where is really where the
data uh and the model are continually
changing
and continually changing so one the
model needs to be regularly retrained
right even if it's every month right
it's it's something that hey i need to
automate this process this is a process
that
needs to be highly automated um and
secondarily and actually almost more
importantly the data is changing
right so not only the training data but
also the feature data and there's
feature pipelines coming in
and then once you start building that
whole system right where you have
feature engineering loops you have
training loops you know your deployments
and
promotions monitoring and visibility
across of that
that's where you know you get into like
machine learning operations or i would
say even continual machine learning
operations uh you know we're operational
and that that's where
you know i would that's what i view as
operational ai
the second part of that it affects the
business so so i mean
that's the second part yeah well let's
let's talk about that so like what what
are some use cases
where um you think this is particularly
meaningful in business
um well they're all over so i mean
there's there's the obvious ones right
like
uh you know sales and marketing related
you know churn and and
you know customer ltv and things like
that which you just you know as a
as especially within a large business
with you know or b2c business where you
have lots of customers
you really need to have those metrics
you need but you fight churn by knowing
who's going to churn
you need to personalize your marketing
uh by figuring out what people are going
to
you know respond to um so there's a
whole you know there's a class of use
cases in in sort of the sales and
operations space
there's a class of use cases in the back
end business operations so things like
supply chain right what are my inventory
a lot of forecasting use cases uh in
those domains
um and then i would say you know i think
one of the things i've
definitely learned about ml is there is
a tremendous
long tail of use cases so when you go
into a
any company uh and you start talking to
them about their data i mean they just
go i mean
you know it's like i have a bot that's
going through a pipeline an
oil pipeline and taking pictures right
and it's
and i'm trying to figure out you know if
the bolts are loose or something that on
the connection joint so i can do
maintenance right
or i you know i remember talking to a
company that was you know they were
trying to
track you know steel beams and they
wanted to use rfid tags but the beams
were so hot because they were coming out
of a steel mill and so they had to put a
paint on them and then they needed a
camera to take the picture of the the
number and
you know and then you know it's not
those are things that i would you know
would not think about right
um there's also you know tremendous you
know in the in the with the rise of nlp
and
text processing and what we can do now
with text there's a tremendous number of
applications where
we're trying to there's continually
continual information coming in from
text and
and whether it's business messages and
support messages and whatnot
how do you get those insights out you
know immediately detect trends
you know figure out bugs you know the
trend trends and bugs uh
customer satisfaction rates um auto you
know auto categorization
just long long long pill and in almost
all those cases
you know hey you have a system that's
can right customer behavior is changing
the world is changing covet hits
right if you if you really want to scale
it and so you're not just stuck
maintaining by hand one use case you've
got to build this highly automated
system right where you can do one use
case let it go on autopilot
move on to the next use case and if you
don't you're going to kind of you know
plateau out there and
not be able to kind of really scale the
the ml use cases
to the degree that you might want which
i've seen you know again and again
so so your your argument is that modern
businesses are just
ill-equipped to handle the complexity of
this kind
of constant continual if you will
updating of their ai models their
training data the features the signal
and um and the types of tools that we
had before
were much more sort of almost like batch
insights oriented
and they're just not suitable or not
suited to the creation of this kind of
continuous learning process in the
modern data world
yeah well yeah exactly i mean i think
we're still stuck in that world i mean i
think
you know i don't you know there's
tremendous excitement around mlabs but
i mean for me having just spent eight
years doing that and
you know you know from my previous and
then kind of getting more and more
towards production
like i am not satisfied with the status
quo of where things are headed like i
don't think people should be satisfied
like a kubernetes platform and a job
system and a monitoring tool
and all of that stuff i mean is it
really necessary you know for for most
applications
when you contrast it where you know you
obviously know that you're there's these
if you don't have to bring your data to
bear right you can use these apis these
serverless things right if you don't
have your own data
and you're going to do speech
recognition or you're going to do you
know now an increasing number like gpt3
you know you can do a lot of
applications without your data
that is just so simple i mean it's 100x
simpler than that
what i was describing so now there's
what i perceive is there's this missing
thing how do we bring a higher level
abstraction
you know dramatically simpler but still
allow you to use your own data right
which most
many many many use cases you use your
own data right so it's your supply
chain your customers your support cases
your pipe you know your your cameras
from your pipelines
that's all you know you're not going to
do that through gpp3 right you got to
bring that data to bear to bear on
and and increasingly increasingly that
data is sitting
in um you know far more mature
data warehouses at least more mature
than when you
started you know in the industry years
ago so
so now we find that that data is landing
in redshift or
bigquery or snowflake um so
then how does continual sort of fit into
the modern data stack because i know you
have
you have thoughts on this as well you're
talking about the power of the customer
bringing their own data
um you know to a more uh sort of a more
nuanced um continuous learning system
so take us the next step i'm sort of
dying to
hear how continual about the the pro
like hey we shouldn't be satisfied i
think uh but you know what what's the
solution and it's not just us there's i
can also talk about what other i think
there are some things coming out of the
academic world
um you know that are that are worth
they're interesting around this right
one potential solutions this
i mean there's another just means to
pause on that because you branch in data
warehouse i think actually another
analogy
is is the sort of the sql analogy you
know if if every time you wanted to do a
model
like or like a like an analytical model
right you're just trying to do some
reporting a bi use case if you had to
write mapreduce
right you know that used to be like on
hadoop that was that was the state right
you had to write if you wanted if you
wanted to do
an analytical question how many active
users do i have using this complicated
definition of activity
on a large amount of data where you
needed to do it in hadoop you had to
write mapreduce jobs
and then okay that's fine you can do it
it's very powerful but oh my gosh the
the productivity challenge of that you
know how slow it is to to to
to build that use case maintain that use
case and then got and then iterate on it
and prove it hey i'm changing my
definition or i'm adding another
so i think there's the same we're the
same we're in like the mapreduce world
for ml is my feeling right like that's
that's the stage it's
we're so excited about big data it's
amazing just now we're
so excited about ai but we're kind of at
the level of abstraction that mapreduce
you know that you know was back then
right and
and we need that a sequel we need that
what is the sequel for ai and it you
know might be related to sql
might be not quite exactly you know
related to sql but it needs to be that
you know higher level abstraction and it
needs to be operational because that
affects the business
so you know that gets to the you know to
your question is how does continual
you know that they're the trend i think
that you you pointed out
um if you want to build a higher level
abstraction you need to think about
where is the right place to plug into
right fundamentally ai and ml is driven
by data
um and so you obviously need to where am
i going to get the data
right and how am i going to expose my
predictions back and i think one of the
you know when i was leaving cloudera we
were you know i was convinced this is
not satisfied with where the status quo
was going but there was kind of a
question well
okay where do you kind of fit in right
um here
and i think what i what you know what i
also have seen i think when everybody's
seen this over the last couple years
is the data warehouse or namely sql
oriented interfaces to data that are
cloud native so i would say you know
that could be lake house or data
warehouse but
it's basically structured data
relational temporal data
sitting accessible via sql in an elastic
you know cloud data environment things
like redshift snowflake
right snowflake obviously is a you know
a huge you know probably the number one
you know example of this databricks with
their delta lake um you know bigquery
uh that's where data is moving to and
even even you know you know customer
data supply chain data
even you know unstructured data right so
if you have images of satellites from
across the world
like hey it should be pretty nice to be
able to query like the metadata
associated with those images
right and you say okay which images have
cars in them or which images
how many you know what is this night or
day or whatever it is you want you know
put it in a structured environment it's
so powerful
um and it's and this and sql has you
know gives you this dramatically easier
workflow especially when things get big
right because big means complex
you know if you don't right if you're on
your laptop and notebook that's fine
so the one so what continual does is
we're trying to build really an
operational ml platform or ai platform
that sits on top of your data warehouse
that sits on top of your
structured data environment so that
we're not doing the data integration
your data integration is happening in
the data warehouse
and the question is now okay well if you
want something that's as easy as sql
but also operational what is that
platform that you put on top or what is
that box that you put on top
and you know we're seeing that in other
parts of this modern data stack that you
know the modern data stack you know
you know i would call it as data
warehouse centric right the data
warehouse lives in the center
you get an emerging ecosystem of tools
that play well together around it
now those can be ingestion tools like
five tran
air bytes et cetera they can be bi tools
of course
uh transformation tools like dbt uh
reverse etl tools like how do you bring
data out of that into your
sas applications and then the question
is well what about ai and ml
how do i if i if i want to do customer
return i want that to be maintained how
do i do that
if i want to do inventory forecasts how
do i do that and so continual
you know we're building an ai platform
you know that has that's declarative
uh that has this much higher level of
abstraction that's operational
and that's you know native to the data
warehouse native did a data warehouse
why
because by being opinionated about that
you know we can
it becomes much easier it becomes opera
we can get access to your data
we can put data back if we want to
namely the predictions
and your whole set of tools all play
well together right so we want to take
over the whole world
we just have to give you you know 10x
simpler ai and ml
uh in an ecosystem that works with you
know what works well with you
so it's like it's like the ai brain that
sits on top of your
your data warehouse essentially um
yeah no internally we always it's always
there's a balance when being started
between marketing uh
and uh you know and reality especially
around ai and ml but
i think conceptually that idea of a
brain is what people want you know you
want uh you know you want if you if you
believe you're in your your business is
going to be ai first
you want to look at something in your
business and saying hey this thing this
is the thing that's
learning that has all the signals that
i'm bringing all the signals to bear on
that i have all my predictions
and so yeah so we are you know we think
of it like building the brain or the
aspirational vision for what we're
trying to do is we're trying to build
the brain
for for businesses um and we're trying
to do and we're doing that in a way that
sits on top of
the data platform for business which is
the modern data stack cloud data
warehouses
mm-hmm got it um so so i'm curious to go
sort of a
a level deeper into the the design
decisions and the architecture
um of continual um what are the core
architectural components of the system
that you're working with
um let me think about that one uh
so um i mean
maybe there's maybe there's three three
core ones uh let's see if i can remember
so so the first one is declarative um
and
um by by that i mean you know we're
trying to take most ml platforms out
there
are sort of are kind of code first and
pipeline first and notebook first
you know they basically are about sort
of stitching together pipe you know
python
scripts and steps and training steps and
all that sort of stuff you know
tensorflow tfx is maybe the example of
like an end-to-end version of that
um what we're trying to do is we're
trying to
raise the level of abstraction where you
have a workflow that's really
data centric so you are organizing
your features and your signals how do
those relate you know what are the
features that you have on your customers
on your products and the core entities
of your business
and what are the targets that's like a
feature store so is that a feature store
component of the architecture
yeah exactly it's a feature store
component but we're doing it on the it's
the second kind of the design choices to
be data warehouse-centric so we're
we're not trying to replicate that data
into our environment and build a feature
store cache kind of thing what we're
trying to do is we're
we're giving you a a a feature store
we're also giving you a you know
there one one aspect is features the
other one aspect is your targets
so exactly so one part of what we're
doing is a feature store that's data
warehouse-centric
right and that gives you a workflow
where you can organize and share your
features across all your use cases
and we carefully take care of the
relational aspects and the temporal
aspects right so what was the feature at
the point in time
but again we do that in the data
warehouse so we make sure that that
exists in the data warehouse the second
one is we we
give you the work and that's sql you
know it's those features are defined
with sql because it's
a data warehouse uh you know we the same
thing we do with respect to your targets
so what are the targets that you have
you know and what are you trying to
predict
right what is your definition of churn
you might have three or four different
definitions of churn
at that point you know our belief when i
say declarative ai is
you've basically done everything that's
necessary that you need to bring your
business knowledge and domain expertise
too
right it's what are the signals what are
the targets that's
i can't automatically automatically do i
need you to
bring your business domain expertise the
rest the pipelines the retraining the
monitoring the drift detection all of
that
it's all it's all stuff that you should
not have to think about
an ideal system whenever that arrives
should not have to do that
you might need to do a little additional
policy for instance do you want
automatic promotions of your models or
do you want to take a look at them first
you know do you want to retrain them
weekly or nightly uh you know things
like that that's all you know how much
money do you want to spend
for a good model right so there's a
little bit of what i would call policy
um but uh you know that that entity is
the level of
the level of complexity that's necessary
but everything else is unnecessary
but you're wrapping you're wrapping all
of these
um sort of services that in in some
systems again sort of back to the
michelangelo example because i think
that's a good one
um you're wrapping a lot of these
services up into one
into one platform so when you talk about
um
uh you know feature store-like stuff um
you're talking about i'm sure some kind
of model management
um whether using automl or something
that's defined by the customer
um there's monitoring there's sort of
all the necessary pieces
that um sort of best of breed or
or build your own systems basically
you know have components for along the
value chain um
you're sort of wrapping that up into one
um piece with this key abstraction
i want to talk about this a little bit
more too you talk a lot about
declarative ai and i think we should
talk about that next
but i just want to first understand like
um make sure i'm grasping sort of what
the architectural components are that
you
are putting into this platform um but i
think you know i i think we got there
well yeah i mean so so in one hand you
know behind the scenes of course there
is a pipeline that's training a model
and there's a there's the model as being
version somewhere and whatnot
um that is true but we are and so in one
hand we're you know end to end
in the sense that we're trying to get
you to the end value namely you have
predictions that are getting better
and better and better you know that and
we do everything that's necessary to do
that
on the other hand if i you know the term
end to end in the ml space you know
typically you have all these nouns on
the side you have your jobs you have all
these things you have your notebooks you
have all these things
uh you know in an end-to-end ml platform
you try to cram it all together and then
you kind of that's all the you know
sagemaker is is like that
we are you know we all of that all of
those
internal things jobs all is behind the
scenes right
it's like sql i mean you don't in this
in a database right you're not going and
seeing i mean unless you go deep into
some debugging ui
you're not actually seeing you know
what's happening you're just writing a
sql query
and we think the exact same way you
should just write your features your
targets
a little tiny bit of configuration
everything else should be on autopilot
and you shouldn't even and it really
needs to be a a non-leaky abstraction if
you do this well
you've got to make that one non-leaky
like sql right so it's you know you
don't
otherwise you know you end up kind of in
the in the complexity world and so if
there's scout and i think there's you
know the question is kind of be pulled
off you know there are skeptics out
there
uh you know i think even myself i was a
code first data scientist can you can
you raise the level of abstraction
one i think we gotta try right uh you
know
because the current status quo can't be
the end of the end of the line of
innovation
um and the second one i would say is um
there's increasing evidence that this is
gonna happen um you know there's a great
paper actually out by chris
ray and uh piero molino so that's from
stanford the snorkel project and the
ludwig project um basically apple has
this declarative ai system called
overton
uber has this one called ludwik they
just wrote a paper on declarative ml
systems
and i think it's increasingly recognized
even in sort of the leading research
area that
there is going to be what you could
think of as a third wave
ml platform that is declarative at the
core right the first wave i would say
was collaboration and r
d oriented the second wave was ml ops in
its traditional kubernetes pipeline kind
of centric way that every
there's about 50 versions of that you
know today and i was a one version of
that
uh in my previous startup and i think
there's a future
which is you know declarative right data
first declarative
uh you know kind of raises the level of
abstraction i think that's where we
ultimately will have to get
it's gonna broaden the access to ml it's
gonna allow it to really
you know become ultimately pervasive um
and i think
if somebody pulls that off and you know
i can feel you know i can see what we're
doing internally that
it's going to happen uh you know then
it's it's going to be quite disruptive
um you know maybe first for people that
you know are
you know don't have any alternative
right they can't go down that
complicated code first path right the
data team that
you know is more analytics oriented um
but ultimately i think it will spread
well i like how you use the the sql
example because
um you know as as a reminder
to all of us um sort of the original the
original declarative language
um maybe not the original one but seems
like the most ubiquitous one is sql
and um i think in the same way that sql
sort of abstracts
um you know all of the the the machinery
and performance and um analytics and
optimization and all the things around
sort of
running that query and and delivering
you the results you're looking for
it seems to me like this is your notion
of of quote operational
or declarative sorry declarative ai in
the sense that
um you know this type of model could be
used for
um to tease insights and to generate
insights from a complicated
ai system and that's what you're going
for
yeah that's yeah that's not exactly
exactly right i mean i think sql is
probably the
most obvious sort of analogy i think you
know for people that are
you know infrastructure people you know
another analogy that often resonates
with them
is the infrastructure as code sort of
the terraform and the kubernetes
declarative cloud infrastructure clearly
we do not
write imperative scripts anymore to
manage our infrastructure to bring them
up to upgrade them
to fix them when they've gone down we
say hey we have auto scaling groups that
i want this many replicas and if things
go back something should correct it and
make it another
you know another bring up another pod or
another virtual machine and you and you
have
and you have a whole workflow that
results from that right
you you know you you have you know maybe
you'll use version you version control
that configuration you do change
management on it right then you can
bring up
dev stacks and prod stacks and all this
stuff and so that core it's a
declarative language
right and so that there's there's a
similar
i think the operational aspect the
analytical aspect is kind of probably
has a more sql flavor to it the
operational aspect has a more terraform
flavor to it
because i would say there's there's a
danger you know the problem is
operational ml and the complexity around
that it's not just you know calling
scikit-learn fit oh is that too
complicated and i need to do that in sql
right so i can learn you know you can
already pretty easily just train a model
in
in python it's not like an amazing
accomplishment to put that into sql and
now you have bigquery ml and you've
you know you have you can write a sql
query that generates a model
it's the whole continual ml operations
aspect of it
and so that's really you know some
people you know look at what we're doing
at continuing oh are you building like a
bigquery ml or redshift ml
no no we're building an operational
oriented platform it's
everything we're doing is operational
right like there's no there's no
model that is an exploit like a like an
r d model every model that's in our
system is like a living breathing model
that's going to continually be
maintained and improve and improve and i
think
you want ml systems that are designed
with that operation you know you need to
start from that operational mindset
um because that's the ultimate problem
that you're trying to you know the
problem and it's the the value that you
um that you want to deliver right well
it's an exciting vision and
um i can't wait to see the the product
and the company continue to
to develop um
so some great ideas there believe it
it's always a secret see it to believe
it i think it's one of those things
where
when you talk about it you know uh so
you know we're we're we're in early
access now you can
you know go to continually eye and you
can you know sign up and you know we'll
let you on it
exists so we'll let people let you on um
uh and we'd love you know we'd love to
work with people on use cases
but i think yeah we're super excited to
to like
just you know give more concrete talks
actually give a demo of this because i
think
that's when the the rubber hits the road
and people will see the potential
you know you can also i would i would
encourage people to go read papers like
the overton paper
you know the ludwig paper this
declarative systems paper there's you
know there's
uh you know if you're skeptical um about
you know can we actually find a higher
level abstraction
um i think the answer is increasingly
yes we can and
let's let's have more people work on it
right not let's let's not have more
pipeline systems and
notebook systems and whatever i mean we
can work on those too and those are
important
let's try to push the envelope a little
further yeah well
thanks for those insights and those
paper references i'm sure people will
take your advice and um and and you know
bone up a bit more on the
on the declarative ml stuff um so
before we let you go since you've spent
so many years on building data tooling
um you know across sort of different
dispensations of
of the modern data ecosystem i'm curious
um what surprised you most about your
work and data
so far
um probably
uh i mean i mean honestly especially
with these recent ipos
probably scale uh the value of
production and the scale of production
um so i actually got it you know what i
mean you know i mean i would say like
you know
the success of databricks and snowflake
for instance you know it's some
it's amazing how big those businesses
are uh and
it's because of the production aspect
the scale of the data that they allow
you to process
and the fact that it's in production um
and one of the things i mean i learned
at sense the previous company was we had
two features we had a notebook-based
feature which was collaboration around
notebooks and we had a kind of a job
system which was really an afterthought
to help you productionize
you know schedule a job or a notebook
that would get run again and again
and what we saw was wow the jobs in
terms of
usage and in terms of usage and business
impact
the jobs were killer because the
notebooks you have seven data scientists
they come onto the platform they open
seven notebooks you know it's kind of
they have seven units of impact
you know on that given day a job a seven
data scientists come in
they build seven new jobs right they
have seven additional units of impact
today tomorrow the next day the next day
the next day
and from a usage perspective it also
goes up right the data gets bigger and
the
and so so you end up having you know
from a business perspective
uh you know from a as a vendor you know
the usage goes up and it's amazing how
big
you know businesses the world economy is
and how global it is and
you know and so it's really that i think
the biggest surprise is just how
large um you know production is within
these companies
um i mean the second i would say
surprising thing which continues to
surprise me is just this long
which i mentioned earlier is this long
tail of applications you know um you
know people always throw out oh churn or
something like that
you know and it gets a little bit you
know okay we've all heard you can do
churn modeling with with ml
but you know when you actually go and
start talking to customers in depth it's
really fun because they bring
all of their little unique uh ideas and
and applications and
it's just it's just you know even within
something like sales and marketing which
you think would be relatively
you know kind of canonical you know yes
there's a whole set of canonical
problems but there's a whole set of
other ones
unique data unique up opportunities and
so that does make
um you know ml you know exciting it also
it shows you the challenge of a vertical
you know platform right so i think the
the like there are tools that are
trying to build vertical you know some
people think everything's going to get
verticalized
um and i think just like bi um there is
always going to be a need for a
horizontal platform right where you will
you can bring all your own data to bear
and not everything is going to get
vertical verticalized um
as a result of that but well um we
surprisingly
we yeah thanks for that um we did get a
question a couple questions in the chat
that i just wanted to um to mention to
you before we sign off
um and this is going to take you back to
sort of the your your
your mental um frame of mind for
continual and
how you're thinking about the company um
jeremy's asking
who's to target buyer and user persona
for the product
is the first question and two as a
customer
what does it take to get up and running
reaching the first instance of value
um so how quickly does the customer sort
of feel value from the system
um so if if you're able to weigh in on
those that would be great
yeah so so the ideal customer for us is
is really like a data team
or an analytics team uh i think that's
the initial market where
they really don't have a great solution
right they don't want to build up a
whole kind of kubernetes-based ml
platform particularly for
you know let's say they're doing
inventory you know some operational
forecasting problem or
where they're a marketing and sales
organization and they're trying to do a
you know they've adopted the modern data
stack right they have
the standard stack there now they want
to go beyond analytics they have their
churn in the last 30 days they want to
do the journey in the next 30 days or
the customer's most likely to churn
you know we really allow them to pull
that off right a team that doesn't maybe
is not sort of as sophisticated or
often they actually are pretty
sophisticated but they really don't have
the time or the resources
to to maintain a like a full ml platform
team and all of that
that's our initial initial thing now my
belief
is that declarative ai is the future
period i mean that is my belief
um so you know and i think it's gonna i
think once you experience
the time to value and once the platforms
mature you know it's going to
there's going to be more and more and
more use cases where you're just going
to want to do it and uh
the ml platforms kind of the engineering
oriented platforms are going to be
left to very very core and they'll like
absolutely mission critical fraud you
know detection systems
that are low latency streaming that are
highly integrated with the rest of the
engineering platform
that you already have so that will
always exist i'm we're not trying to
replace that
um like you know completely replace that
but i think more and more use cases
just you know as you start to use apis
that are you know don't even require
data to do things
more and more use cases will move
towards a declarative approach
so so um so yeah starting with the you
know analytics and data teams
um kind of you know data scientists
machine learning research engineers
you know are going to be doing their own
thing for the foreseeable people um
in terms of time to value uh i mean
minutes right that's the magic and i
mean minutes like not just minutes on
training and training
i mean minutes on a model that is in
production that is getting better and
better
uh and and that's the beautiful thing
about
the two two sort of design choices we
made one is to bet on the data warehouse
all you need to do is give us those
credentials we'll take over a schema
we'll start managing your features and
your predictions there
and so we don't have any of the data
integration challenges that most ml
platforms have data and
your data is already there you already
have a workflow using dbt to clean it up
to do some feature
advanced feature engineering ingestion
is already happening
you already have it hooked up to your bi
tools so not only do you get access to
the data but
the predictions we make can also be
impacting your business immediately
via your reporting functionality via
your downstream and data engineering
via your reverse etl into your sas
applications you know
um so all that happens that's this just
that's the turnkey impact right
and then our workflow our declarative
workflow
means that you know minutes to
to get to your first use case and it
gets easier and easier i mean once you
have all your features around your kind
of core entities it tends to be you're
building
you know a dozen models on your
customers right not just one
so you started okay here are the things
that i know about my customers how
active have they been in the last week
and you have that going back in time now
you can build your upsell cross-cell
you know churn ltv all those models
where in our system you all only need to
define your target you don't even need
to define your features anymore we'll
bring all that stuff
in um and so we and then you you know
you have this uh kind of
uh you know very rapid workflow so i
think that's the
you know that's when i think about oh
wow i'd have to set up an airflow dag
and
i'd train it how to monitor it and i
love the i always love the power of code
i'm at the
core i love the power of code at one
hand but i'm also like never again would
i do that for that use case and i think
that's gonna
you know spread you know spread spread
out yeah
yeah that sounds really powerful and
it's awesome to be able to give
customers
um such a short time to value so um so
that's great
tristan um thanks for coming on and for
for sharing with us some of your
inspiration and um you know you're
obviously a very passionate guy and it's
awesome always awesome to hear to hear
your thoughts
on the space so um so thanks for joining
us today we all really appreciate it
yeah pete thank you so much yeah i
appreciate it
uh and to the rest of our listeners i
just wanted to mention that our next
event is on august 5th
we'll be having anapan who's a
co-founder
of a company called truera and annapum
and i will be talking about
machine learning quality and monitoring
in that chat
so until next time thanks for joining us